Education, education, education.
Some people say that's
the key to success
in this knowledge-based
economy that we're in.
And they're right.
But the reality is
the education model
that we have inherited
today was built
for the farming economy and
maybe the industrial economy
of the last century.
And so we're going
to have to adapt
it to meet the needs of the
next generation workforce.
And you, as members of the
next generation workforce,
are going to have to
have your own strategy
for addressing how,
when, where, and how much
over the course of
your life of education
you are going to invest in.
Let's start with early
childhood education.
And I'll start with a story.
Several months
ago, I was sitting
at a lunch with international
students here at MIT.
And they were
mid-career students.
And so I was sitting between
two mothers, one from Portugal
and one from China.
And I asked them, when
did your children start
school in your countries?
And one said, right after
I finished maternity leave.
And the other
said, at age three.
They were amazed to hear from
me that basically our children
in this country start in
kindergarten at age five,
unless there's some
private alternative.
Well, about 70% of the
industrialized world
starts education earlier.
So why is this so important?
Well, let's take a look.
This is Professor James
Heckman from the University
of Chicago, a Nobel
Prize-winning economist.
And he is the world's
expert on the economics
of early childhood education.
He has studied this
in experiments,
he's studied it in Chicago, he's
studied it around the world.
And what he finds is
that there's a 7% to 10%
rate of return for society for
every year of early childhood
education.
That return is measured not
only in lifetime earnings.
It's measured in lower
dropout rates, less violence
and less criminal
records, the ability
to achieve one's objectives
within one's career.
A whole set of data tell us that
getting children into school
early is very, very
important to their success.
Well, it's even more important
for children who are at risk.
Inner city students from
disadvantaged neighborhoods
have even higher rates of return
for early childhood education.
So it's very clear
that if we want
to have the next generation's
children well educated
so they can move on to achieve
their dreams in the workforce,
then we have to
get on with this.
The challenge is that
it's very expensive.
The good news is that mayors
and governors around the country
are beginning to
recognize the importance.
So from Seattle to New York to
Boston and many other cities,
we're seeing mayors
take the lead in saying,
let's figure out how we invest
in early childhood education,
and let's get on with that task.
For individual parents,
it is very expensive.
And so we have to work
together as a community
to figure out how we
can fund early childhood
education for all.
And for every
parent, it's critical
that you think as
you can about what
do you need, what do your
children need, what's
appropriate for different age
groups, from early childhood
right through elementary
school, what can you afford,
and how can you make it fit
into your work and other family
responsibilities.
But if we don't
start early, then we
will pay the price later.